- You say hook up, it's the sex.
You're bumping bellies.
That's just (claps).
(country music)
- Me and my friends, we
get along pretty well
and we usually agree on everything.
But there's one thing we
just can't seem to agree on,
and that is, what it means to hook up.
So, I'm gonna go around the office
to ask my coworkers what
it means to hook up,
and hopefully we could all
finally come to an agreement.
From making out to anal,
where would you land the
beginning of hooking up?
- The beginning of hooking up
is probably just making out,
'cause that could go into hooking up.
Once we get into anal, you're dating.
- We need you and your
expertise for this video.
- Oh.
- We're trying to figure out
what it means to hook up,
and like,
(laughs)
- I think hooking up would definitely be
if one private part meets
another private part.
- More than just making out.
Otherwise you would just say,
"I made out with that person."
- A hand job.
Would you consider a hand job hooking up?
- Then a person would just be like,
"I gave them a hand job."
- Oh, so if it's a hookup
there's more things.
- Yeah.
- What do you think it means to hook up?
- I honestly think you need
to exchange some bodily fluids
for it to count as a hookup.
- I wouldn't really go anything further
than making out, I don't think.
I know people think it means sex,
and I don't think that
they're wrong either.
- If someone says, "oh, yeah we hooked up"
it means you had an orgasm together.
- Anything past kissing.
So, clothes off.
- I think it means
anything kissing or beyond.
- Let's say you went out
and you kissed someone.
- You hooked up.
- I'm married.
And if my wife kissed
somebody, I would say,
"Oh, you hooked up with someone!"
And then we would be divorced.
- As a hookup, I would say
anything past just making out.
- Anybody else has an opinion about that?
- I think it's having sex, right?
- Come here.
- Everything that--
- [Woman] Sorry.
- Yes, thank you, Confrontation.
- If my friend came up to me and was like,
"I hooked up with someone last night."
I'm like, "Oh, she had
sex with him or her."
- Would you be like, "you
didn't hook up with them"
if they were like, "no, we just,
I just sucked his dick."?
- Yeah.
- You'd be like, "that's not a hookup"?
- That's not a hookup.
(bell chimes)
- Oh.
- Oral sex is still sex.
- My guess, anything after making out.
- P to V, V to V, P to P?
I probably wouldn't say
that a make-out is a hookup.
- [Fernando] What about a hand job?
- That's a hookup, I think.
- I could come here and tell you,
"Oh, I hooked up with
this person last night."
And you wouldn't automatically
assume that I had sex?
- With you?
Automatically, automatically.
It depends on the person.
I haven't went out with
this person before.
- Thank you so much.
This was great.
- Oh, really?
- I think when exposed
genitalia are involved,
that's when the hookup line hits.
- More than kissing.
It could be heavy touching, heavy petting,
fondling if you will.
- Horsing around.
Horsing around, yeah.
- It's beyond making out,
touching each other's bits.
- You gotta be naked for a hookup.
Doesn't have to be sex.
- Making out naked, is that a hookup?
- Yeah.
- There was some genitalia involved.
It wasn't just a make-out.
- Anything beyond making out,
you can fill in with hookup
and then you just get into more details
depending on who you're
telling the story to.
- Then you have what they call hookin' UP.
- Oh, yeah, yeah.
If you're hooking up,
"Yo, I been hooking up with this girl."
Usually that means you've
been sleeping with a girl.
- For me, I feel like hooking
up involves sex in some way,
whether it's oral or penetration.
- Like a hand job.
Would you consider that hooking up?
- That's interesting.
I
don't think so.
Even though it is sexual.
(jazz music)
- After this, I think I'm more okay
with having a loose definition for hookup,
even though I wish we would
could all agree on something.
We'll remain confused until
we all get our shit together,
and agree on something.
(coughs awkwardly)
I feel like I'm just as
confused as I was earlier.